[Musica]
Buonasera
poco fa Avete sentito parlare di
metaverso
io non ho capito bene cos'è il metaverso
ancora ma ho capito che è un mondo
virtuale però dove è un mondo dove la
gente si incontra si vede parla
virtualmente Ma è un mondo Quasi uguale
al nostro
Io sono un microbiologo
io
lavoro con
un buon invisibile
le cose in cui lavoro io non si vedono
non parlano non c'è interazione
Eppure
eppure non impatto enorme sul nostro
pianeta sulla vita di tutti i giorni
oggi quello che volevo fare
farvi fare un viaggio nel mio mondo Nel
mondo invisibile
e
cosa troverete ma troveremo
tante cose si trovano
tantissimi
microrganismi che non sono mai visibili
a occhio nudo
ce ne sono mille miliardi di specie
dove sono Sono dappertutto negli oceani
nell'aria nel suolo dappertutto
e
lo so
la prima di vita sul nostro pianeta
3,8 miliardi di anni fa e i
microrganismi hanno cominciato a vivere
popolare il nostro pianeta e da allora
derivata la vita gli altri gli animali
tutto era derivato da loro e
essenzialmente sono
dappertutto fanno tutte queste cose e ce
ne sono di tutti i tipi ci sono quelli
buoni e ci sono quelli cattivi e oggi ve
ne farò incontrare alcuni in questo
viaggio che faremo e per incontrare il
primo
partiamo da un posto che c'è molto
vicino
Siena e facciamo un passo indietro nel
tempo
inizio del 1300
se non è una città ricca bella che sono
qui vedete la maestà di Duccio che sta
al duomo a Siena e c'erano una città
dove c'erano pittori che hanno lasciato
un'impronta nella storia enorme questo è
Duccio questo è Ambrogio Lorenzetti
E perché c'era queste cose assieme
perché Siena era una città molto ricca a
quel tempo era sulla Cassia
e che congiungeva Roma al nord Europa e
tutti devono passare da lì per andare
per andare al nord Europa e tutti
tornando su Roma devono passare di lì e
quindi se noi siamo stati bravissimi
erano diventati
messo sul commercio messo su un ospedale
messo su
delle banche riuscivano a prestare soldi
e così via così erano diventati molto
ricchi molto ricchi e potevano attrarre
i migliori pittori del tempo i migliori
architetti migliori scultori è una
cultura violentissima
a Siena c'erano
che sa 70 forse 100 mila persone più di
oggi Parigi a quel tempo ne aveva meno
di insieme
e in quella atmosfera incredibile di
ricchezza di sedersi
volevano fare qualcosa di grande
qualcosa che rimanesse nella storia
e oggi se volete rimanere nella storia
si fa l'edificio più alto del mondo a
quel tempo si faceva la Cattedrale più
grande al mondo
e cominciare una costruirla avevano gli
architetti pittori eccetera costruire ne
vedete quel
il facciatone erano stavano costruendone
arrivati in su a fare questa facciata
che guardava al sud la gente che veniva
da Roma e gli doveva dire Guardate Dove
state entrando in che città state
era maggio del 1348 arrivò il nostro
amico invisibile un batterio un batterio
piccolo invisibile che in tre mesi
decimò due terzi della popolazione
uccise pittori gli architetti
distrusse l'economia cambiò Il volto
della storia in tre mesi a settembre era
tutto fatto
e oggi è quello che c'è il cacciatore
Cacciatore che è essenzialmente lì ad
ricordarci il sogno Questo è il duomo
che abbiamo oggi nel Duomo che doveva
essere questo qui non si è mai
realizzato
e
cos'è il pancione che staglio in piazza
del Duomo per me è più grande Monumento
alle malattie infettive o ai microbi Se
volete è una cosa che ci ricorda che un
microbo piccolo invisibile può arrivare
in un posto può distruggere una con mia
economia uccidere tante persone e
essenzialmente e cambiare il corso della
storia
Questa è la storia di Siena è una cosa
che io racconto sempre un po' nel mondo
perché è una cosa importante
i microbi abbiamo visto uno di quelli
cattivi ma
nel mondo vi ho detto ci sono un
trilione un trilione sono 1000 miliardi
di specie
cosa fanno
fanno tutto
le cose più comune fare il vino abbiamo
bisogno la birra il pane
è fertilizzare il suolo la vita negli
oceani del tutto tutto lo dobbiamo amico
nel nostro intestino ci sono
4.000 miliardi di batteri e sono lì
senza di loro non ce la facciamo non
vivremmo servono per la digestione
servono per il nostro sistema immune e
quindi
questi
batteri sono quelli cioè questi microbi
sono quelli che mantengono la vita sul
nostro pianeta
ma
non sono tutti buoni su mille miliardi
di specie
999,99 miliardi sono
buoni sono quelli che ci permettono di
avere la vita nel nostro pianeta però ci
sono 1400 specie che sono quelle cattive
uno di questi l'abbiamo visto su Siena e
cosa facciamo
noi facciamo delle cose orribili
prendiamo gli antibiotici se abbiamo
un'infezione quasi cosa facciamo quando
prendiamo un antibiotico prendiamo un
antibiotico vogliamo uccidere un
batterio cattivo uccidiamo tutti i 40
miliardi che ci sono nel nostro
intestino come una bomba atomica
distrugge tutto ci rimane niente
e Cosa succede quando usiamo questi
antibiotici a grande spettro niente
essenzialmente quello che succede è che
uccidiamo tutti e ci sono alcuni su come
i numeri sono tanti Ci sono alcuni che
riescono a resistere e diventare
resistenti e quelli si propagano e di
solito sono quelli cattivi quindi
e poi abbiamo i fertilizzanti poi usiamo
gli antibiotici per allevare le mucche e
i polli usiamo 60.000 tonnellate
all'anno di antibiotici solo per
crescere e I bovini e i polli nel mondo
e questi antibiotici cosa fanno vanno
negli oceani vanno nei fiumi vanno le
cose e distruggono tutta questa
ricchezza dei microbi e gli sta
essenzialmente fanno sì che vengono
fuori solo in microbi resistenti e
Essenzialmente per questo motivo
recentemente ha scritto un lavoro di cui
vedete la cosa in cui ho detto questo
pianeta Oggi abbiamo due soluzioni
quella verde a destra dove Dobbiamo
cominciare a rispettare i microbi buoni
che sono la maggior parte o quella
sinistra Continuiamo con gli antibiotici
disinfettanti continuiamo a buttare
tutte le cose sul pianeta il nostro
pianeta degenererà
e quindi
mio motto è Salviamo i microbi se
vogliamo salvare il pianeta
un altro microbot cattivo l'abbiamo
appena visto
è arrivato ha avuto un impatto enorme 20
milioni di morti
28 miliardi trilioni di
costo all'economia globale una volta e
mezzo il PIL americano
non vi dirò molto di più sul comico
l'abbiamo vissuto tutto Sapete Le
conseguenze sapete ci ha tolto la
libertà non potevamo andare a giro non
potevamo andare al lavoro non potevamo
fare più niente un microbo che non
vediamo
paralizzato il mondo
E adesso che questo lo stiamo un po'
controllando anche se non è finito ci
diciamo Ma come facciamo ci saranno
altre pandemia Sì ve lo assicuro ce ne
saranno degli altri
riesco a dirvi quale non non tutte ma ce
n'è una di sicuro che riesco a dirvi
Qual è che quello dei microbi resistenti
agli antibiotici
antibiotico e resistenza sono sicuro che
ne avete sentito parlare Tanti ma c'è
uno studioso inglese che nel 2014 ha
fatto uno studio economico guardato al
microbiosistenti gli antibiotici ha
detto che essenzialmente
nel 2014 uccidevano ogni anno 700 mila
persone
e ha detto che se non avremmo fatto
niente nel 2050 nevrebbero uccisi e
avrebbe ucciso 10 milioni più dei Tumori
oggi e
è una pandemia è una pandemia che
l'abbiamo nel nostro paese e che se non
facciamo niente continuerà a uccidere
sempre più persone
e è vero che nel 2050 avremo 10 milioni
di morti nel 2014 erano 700 mila l'anno
scorso è stato detto che oggi ce ne sono
già 5 milioni di morti aveva
sottostimato nel quanto ci saranno più
morti di quanti pensiamo se
riusciamo a fare qualcosa nel frattempo
e
Quali sono i batteri pericolosi
salmonella il buonococco cressella
stafilococco pseudomonas
cosa possiamo fare
io nel mio piccolo sto lo faccio vaccini
faccio
anticorpi monoclonali Cerco fondi per
fare e la ricerca che faccio e
perché faccio vaccini e anticorpi
monoclonali
perché queste sono armi intelligenti
i monoclonali non riconoscono come gli
antibiotici al grande spettro tutti i
batteri uccidono tutti riconoscono solo
quello che abbiamo
che vogliamo colpire e uccidono solo
quello i vaccini i vaccini fanno
esattamente lo stesso sono armi
intelligenti non vanno a uccidere tutto
ma vanno chiuse solo quelli che sono
cosa facciamo quando facciamo i vaccini
quando facciamo i vaccini abbiamo
io quando parlo di vaccini dico cosa
sono i vaccini di solito dico Avete
presente un simulatore di volo
i piloti
o meglio quelle che vogliono diventare
piloti
non vanno
sugli aerei gli dicono adesso vai e
distruggi questo aereo tutti quelli che
ci sono sopra mentre sta imparando mi
mettono in simulatore di volo dove c'è
un bel computer c'ha vedere tutto e
essenzialmente imparano a guidare
virtualmente il loro aereo nelle zone
più tempestose nelle zone più pericolose
negli nelle cose più inaspettate di modo
che quando saranno piloti esperti e che
incontreranno queste cose le hanno già
simulate sanno già cosa fare
cosa facciamo quando facciamo i vaccini
esattamente la stessa cosa
Facciamo incontrare dei microbi uccisi
oppure del microbi simulati
con il nostro sistema immune
e il nostro sistema immune li vede tocca
le guarda le conosce e impara
a fronteggiarli quando ci sarà
un'infezione è questo che quello che
faccio io tutti i giorni
è una cosa che secondo me è perché
riesce a colpire solo le cose che
vogliamo colpire non danneggia
l'ambiente non danneggia il pianeta Anzi
io la trovo una soluzione Verde a queste
cose
quindi finendo cosa dobbiamo fare
sabrà
Salvo guardare la biodiversità microbica
fare ricerca perché per fare quello ci
vuole innovazione e ci dobbiamo far
trovare pronti a affrontare le grandi
sfide E spero che microbi che vi ho
fatto incontrare oggi di Sappiate
rispettare perché sono l'essenza della
vita e senza di loro il nostro pianeta
non ci sarebbe vita nel nostro pianeta e
con questo vi ringrazio per la vostra
attenzione
[Applauso]